and then for Ben it's probably about
what time it's about 9 p.m. at night so
Ben's gonna join us he's the CTO and
co-founder of a Luxio great and he's
going to give us a talk on big analytics
in the cloud so Ben can you hear us
yes I can hear it clearly oh wow this is
amazing
so we I have a whole room of data geeks
here in Singapore and they're dying to
hear what you have to say so I hope
you're ready yes I'm ready
okay thank you yeah we'll take it away
yeah hi everyone good morning actually
I'm here to present how we build a
detoxication layer for beginning the
analytics in the clouds so as mentioned
I'm Ben from Alex ooh and I'm glad to be
here and tell you our externa
to build this the dark situation layer
and what we can do for different use
cases so this is a little bit about me
and you have my email my twitter handle
and my kid hub account a little bit
history into a Luxio it was a research
project called young in the early days
and you can think this is a sister
project for alex e4 for apache spark in
UC berkeley unplowed and this was the
research project the PhD thesis for a
PhD student housing Lee who was the
founder of this project and later on in
2015 we open source age project and we
established a company to commercialize
Alexio as a technology but the company
and the team committed is committed to
move forward with the open source
technology and one of the founder is and
one of the investor is from the and
recent hordes we have different media
coverage for the company and for the
project as I mentioned this is the open
source project and we're so excited to
see every day this open source community
is growing so far we have more than
thousand contributors in github - to
fast growing our project has 4,000 more
github stars and we have a community
slag Channel you are welcome to join us
in a slant childhood engage with the
experts and also the community users the
software itself is under a patch to
license its most one of the most
permissive license just as similar to a
lot of other applications and software
in the Big Data ecosystem the software
has been downloaded for a more than
hundreds of thousands times from our
binary downloading and also from darker
downloading I want to give you a little
bit more history and also the motivation
for why we're doing this system if you
go back to ten years ago that's how you
are dealing with data ecosystem big data
ecosystem on a storage side you are
pretty much using HDFS as the only
storage solution for your big data
analytics and on the computation side
Hadoop MapReduce is perhaps the owning
choice and that right at that time as a
stable solution for you to be able to
process and analyze a huge amount of
data like data a skill however if you
look at a today the landscape has been
dramatically different on the
computation side we have been saying
more and more computation especially
open source computation frameworks
showing up and they are more getting
more and more specialized in different
subdomains in this ecosystem for example
if you are dealing with streaming system
is a fling or like spark streaming yzma
are maybe your choices and if you are
dealing with key value stores and this
can be HBase or some other choices and
if you're dealing with interactive big
data queries and presto or spark Seco
can be your friends and even ladies
lately we see a lot of choices in deep
learning frameworks Inc
being Cafe tensorflow and many others so
the data ecosystem in the data ecosystem
the computation choices it's getting
more and more and also the good news is
we are also having a richer and richer
choice in terms of how do you put the
data for example in addition to
traditional HDFS we also now this having
a lot of users using at Mount Amazon s3
as the data Lake to store a large amount
of data similarly for other cloud
vendors we see a Microsoft Azure and
Google or Google car engine yeah so you
still see more and more different
choices from either cloud vendors or
from hardware vendors to provide
solutions to store big data and given
this change in the past 15 or 10 years
we also see a very interesting journey
associated with a lot of different
contents in terms of building their big
data ecosystem big data infrastructure
inside a lot of companies are
organizations they started with a
communicated compute for HDFS and a
compute and HDFS
so basically you deploy a bunch of boxes
in each box you're running MapReduce
demons and HDFS demons so in this way
you are deeply optimized for data
locality instead of moving data to
computation this is basically followed
by the Google file system paper a
MapReduce paper that following the
philosophy moving computation to data so
this is great
colocation to compute and storage
however this typically results in a
compute bound storage can compute bound
cluster and it's very hard to scale
computation and i/o independently in
this case because these two dimensions
are deeply coupled it's very hard for
you to say I just want buy more CPUs
rather than just also spending time in
investing on disks
for a lot of use cases we see use his
users are exploring the architecture to
have disaggregating aggregated compute
and storage essentially the idea is have
a different set of machines running one
pool is running computation the atom of
machines is running it like storage like
HDFS so we have this disaggregated
computer storage and this will give you
the flexibility to independently scale
two dimensions however a lot of users
are still complaining I want to if I
want to store all my bytes of HDFS it
can be expensive we see a typical
journey nowadays in recent years people
are talking about how to share data
across datacenters but without changing
the applications and also another very
popular choice for a lot of enterprises
to seek the opportunity burst their
workloads for example birthday or HDFS
data into the cloud public cloud public
or private clouds and when you burst
this data into the cloud you don't have
to always use the computation resource
from account that you just always pay
and just pay for the results you need
and in this case and get a much better
efficiency in the resource efficiency
and also another trend we see is to
migrating their HDFS conventional HDFS
data as a lake to achieve her Moore's
capable and easier to maintain services
like obvious work so this can enable and
accelerates big data objects or but
migrating data from HDFS so these are
the data stack churning we see in the
past few years and this is what we are
proposing our motivation is to build
another layer into this data stack so
instead of having better computation or
build a better storage we realize that
compute either computation and a storage
they are evolving constantly due to new
hardware due to new workload
so what we're doing here is to build
another layer between the computation
and storage and you can think this is
the data orchestration they are
providing a data abstraction and also
data policies in our Norris boundary
called like an our interface into the
interface talking to application cuz
it's in our spouts we provide different
popular ap is representing the same data
abstraction - presto - spark - MapReduce
and - there's to our southbounds that
there are drivers talking to this
physical and maybe remote or dispersed
physical storage engines like s3 or a
doer or HDFS so in this case we can
provide the data abstraction in this
case apps applications don't need to
worry about how do i connect to each
individual physical data stores but just
talk to this abstraction that's enough
and within this layer we can install
different data policies including data
caching for the holiday that we can
cache data in this layer including
studying TTLs
including migrating data from one
physical store to the other including
some time time based policies like a
synchronously or asynchronously
propagated data from one layer to
another so there's a whole lot of
different things you can do with this
new data orchestration for the cloud so
in this slide I want to show you flavor
how people how users are interacting
with this layer as you can see for
applications like spark a presto which
are lab reaching HDFS interface their
way to access data it's basically the
same semantics you just change from HDFS
comma slash slash into a log sukima / /
because we also provide a POSIX
compatible interface and you can mount a
log Co as a service into your local
laptop or local desktop and then you can
use your familiar Linux commands like a
cat or LS or D you to check
see and read and write data from this
alexa service just as you're interacting
with your local files in your local
folders and in the end we also provide a
java api which is very similar to Java
file system and this is the basically
this is the file system API you can
leverage most or the complete a set of
functionalities from Alexio so yeah
so we provide the same set of data
abstraction but two different api's up
to the choice from it users I want to go
through a few use cases we think most
relevant to to the audience here the
first case is as a distributed caching
layer for cloud storage like a GCS or s3
we know that for s3 the performance can
be variable and also if we want to
ensure consistent occurring latency as
SLA sometimes it's hard to achieve
because s3 just like a it's a remote to
our application and also it's just like
a black box and what's more a lot of
metadata operations to s3 actually is
not really a thousand system so a lot of
metadata operations like a list in
pockets or rename a object can be
expensive because as through
implementation is different from the
file system and the egress cars in
adding up and also making a solution
more expensive if you just microdata
constantly to the to the to the clouds
finally the eventual consistent thing is
very well known that it's trouble is a
trouble for a lot of applications which
is not designed dealing its kind of
overriding the eventual consistency when
overriding objects into a locks into s3
so in this case we see a lot of users
are are applauded a Luxio as a
co-located distributed storage caching
layer for applications like an EMR spark
or yellow are hostile or their own
applications so you can install a lot to
you in this way to bring up the data
locality which is missing this picture
so if thinking this week Spock is
directly talking to s3 or GCS then you
do have data locality anymore right you
know you've always track data from the
remote server theater service and in
this case if you if you whistle Axio in
this case if you are accessing data with
some data look holiday then this seemed
you the traffic of beating rapidly from
s3 but also provide you a consistent and
the latency data retrieval the next use
case we see a lot of cases to are a lot
of users is the user lock so as a data
Federation layer in the hybrid cloud so
it think in this way if you have a data
in HDFS but you want to leverage the
objects to the the resource public
vendors like running past of there but
you do want to really retrieve that
repeated yeah pass that you can just
install a lock city as one layer to hide
this deploy the same object in an
opposite way you can move your data to
cloud storage and run a computation in
your object in your on demarks in your
own data warehouse and using a Luxio as
the layer to access data and you can
have data in post places in both hs3 and
also in your own data warehouse and
using a lock so as the federation layer
to unify because we are providing data
abstraction and doesn't matter where
data is really physically and
persistently stored and using this need
abstraction layer your applications or a
logic to deploy and maintain
applications can be very simple so this
is basically a provision in the long run
if you can have a data oxidation layer
and you may have different choices to
run your applications in your own data
centers you may have even motivated if
your different data centers and you can
have party applications in your some
like your resource rendered from the
public cloud vendors and then by having
this data oxidation layer it will just
make everything very simple every
everyone sing
same-day abstraction and a data
migration the data
persistency and also data propagation
will be handled by this oxidation layer
without applications to worry about how
do I really implement enforce these
different policies your company or your
environment really wants to achieve yeah
so the key innovations in order to
achieve this orchestration layer include
a lot of engineering work to improve the
data locality by having something like a
marine layer caching and the data
accessibility by providing different
popular api's and api translate on a
server side as well as data electricity
with a unified namespace i will go
through the three and two and three
bullets in more details this is how we
improve data locality so essentially we
build a tissue storage engine come up
with a Luxio
and we've been this engine you can
allocate different tiers one tier for
example one tier is allocated with
random one tier is allocated with SSD
and one tier is allocated with hard disk
or some combination like this and we
because we are not targeting as a
storage this is really we're just try to
optimize the performance optimize the
data layout data storage for computation
the performance the computation to a
motel okay some part of data is very hot
let's just cache the data into this
layer and some other part of data is not
that hot it's warm
okay let's maybe put it into the SSD
chair and some code data can be put into
hardest here some other data because
they are not used according to the
prediction for data access pattern we
can maybe just elite them out because
the whole the entirety of the data is
still stored in persistent storage so it
doesn't matter if you evict them out
next time if the application needs them
we can't just always transparently load
them back so this is the how we achieve
data locality with the body cheering
hashing to improve the local performance
from reading remote data
as I mentioned earlier we provide
different interfaces and for different
applications they may have their own
favorite interface for spark faster or
how to reproduce typically they want to
use a
hdfs interface so that's one way to
access the data except an obstruction a
form or 20 pensive low or cafe this type
of deep learning frameworks they are
more they are more used to access data
and assume data is on a local disk so
you can they can use our POSIX interface
and to our southbounds because we have a
set of different drivers talking to the
physical stores then we can always
choose this is basically under the hood
and the transparent to users or
applications so we can always choose
dynamically which drivers to use to
access the data including the su driver
HDFS driver the interesting part is we
can even use a different version of HDFS
driver then the HDFS interfaces we are
exposing for example we can talk to HDFS
one but we are exposing HDFS three as an
interface to applications or we can have
multiple HDFS drivers one in version one
one in version two running version
Street and we combined them into one
single namespace and exposing a single
HDFS 3 interface to the applications so
this is the power this demo states the
power of having this interaction and
having this abstraction layer so the
last part is validated elasticity how we
achieve unified namespace so essentially
on your laptop you can easily mount
different disks into your local file
system because the all intimate
for example the Linux VFS API so in that
case we can just mount it as a different
implementation for this VFS device and
it's a similar case here but instead of
having a single node filesystem we
extend this idea to distribute it and
remote file systems or storage systems
so you can mount a s3 buckets into one
of the directory in the Al Aqsa logic
system and you can also mount for
example the hdfs should be a logic the
root for the logical file system of a
Luxio
here we see more excuses
by adding a luxu at the POSIX API by a
mountain of hot soup CPI and mounting
luxio as a local folder the service show
up a local border in fact different
directories that are backed by different
storages but from user's perspective
this is a hit of business transparent so
we have a lot of companies using a Luxio
and i will go through a few cases that
might be relevant to the topic here so
one use cases are from a digital
marketing company in Austin their use
cases to accelerates their data speed
data access pattern from hi to a diverse
as three so they have a lot of data
stored in it addressed as three but the
O's only want to cache a certain
partitions so these certain partitions
they are frequently accessed by a lot of
different jobs in this way their hive
jobs do not need to repeatedly go to ask
you to read the data and the way they
achieve this is to deploy a luxu
co-located with hive and for certain for
certain partitions to cap for example
the latest 30 days and for the latest 30
days of the data will be stored in a
Luxio but the entirety of the data still
in s3 as the data like so in this way
they claim they see an electro form as
gained by having the memory first data
proach and here's the link to access
their block so we have another use case
from China Unicom and they are using
Alexio as a way to speed up their spark
performance and they originally they
have different data source - for spark -
processes that have to run in here our
jobs to track data from one data source
to their spark cluster so by having data
extraction of like Alexio besides
running together with a spark and hiding
the
- loading data from the external storage
into this storage running start there
because saved cost running ETL and also
because the memory first approach you
get a much more perfect game yeah
so the rest of part of the talk I will
go through very quickly about the
architecture state of flowy elección so
similar to most of the digital file
systems we have the masternodes
managing the metadata and the more
kernels managing the real data serving
the data to the cloud and we unique
points in this picture is we do have a
concept called end store which is the
persistent layer for the data so a lot
of workers can you can think this is
provides a distributor caching layer for
data but the persistency four-blade data
is provided in the object store or and
HDFS you mounted into a lock seal and
inside it locks you each logical file is
divided into logic blocks and one logic
block can be in one will curl multiple
workers and the same blocks can be
replicated to multiple Heights also
different blocks can be distributed
differently across different workers to
achieve load balancing and also to have
higher bandwidth to access and in the
end we also provide a way to for users
to set their own block size according to
all their their use cases and what we
see is if you run in the traditional
MapReduce jobs which reading
sequentially for whole lot of data in
one file and the default both big block
size can improve the performance if
you're running the sequel close opening
the 2/3 the files like it's arcade files
and then smaller block size can have
result at a point and this is basically
the architecture for the master you have
them RPC service you calculated parses
the blog meta data and also worker
metadata and because we provide
efficient we wear another layer we also
know
we also serve metadata as on top f3 we
can avoid expensive but listing in Alex
aes3 and this is becomes a very key and
important optimization for spark Seco or
present world what I also do we name
becomes very efficient because in our
land this is you a very easy I know
change versus industry the name becomes
a copy and a delete and also we batch
and restore operations to s3 to have
higher performance and here are the
different sources we how we can achieve
better and the more efficient metadata
operations OS 3 and on a data site we
provide a data service and this is the
difference like RPC service and also
data transfer service on the worker side
and we apply different innovations like
we to avoid JVM see we store the blocks
of heap like for example the RAM disk
and we have tiered storage data and it
latest version we also use that G RBC is
the streaming RPC service stuff to
improve the data throughput and we
provides a way to asynchronously archive
data to a street from you can write it
it allows your first and then
asynchronously persist data to s3 so yes
here because we are adding a new layer
we are having different modes to write
and read data for example we can read
data if the data is already in Alexio
then we just read this directly and
co-located if this will provide you
bastard performance if this is an odd
cache it cache hit but rather than cash
this then the client will talk to the
master and the master will instruct a
walker to fetch data for these clients
and meanwhile you can just also cache
the data into this local worker so next
time when a same client is required if
any client is requesting the same block
data and we will be able to serve this
from Luxio space
similarly on right path because we have
the new layer you can either choose to
write you this allows you layer only
which is a which is shown here or you
can decide to write data
persistence two ns you're acing
synchronously so after this operation
completes you know the data will be
cached into a lot of space but also
persisted into the Ender store and we in
a 2.0 VDS we also provide a new approach
you can write the data to a lots of
space first and then asynchronously to
the end a store and we have a lot more
interesting architectural improvements
in a 2.0 which is released last month so
this concludes my talk and I'm willing
to take a few more questions
thanks Ben
any questions for Ben
all right well Ben thank you for joining
us from Olli we appreciate your efforts
thank you thank you have a great evening
have a Guzzi right back
bye-bye